attention Guardians this is Miss revenge
okay walking royalty
multiple issues
the reef is now open to you destiny is a
game that has always displayed stunning
technical expertise but has struggled
with basic game mechanics such as
leveling rewarding players for their
efforts and storytelling when I talk
about destiny it's always in relation to
a rate of improvement rather than with
any committed good bad statement I can
honestly say them that destiny is a game
that is steadily improving adding
content adding story adding variety and
doing it at a decent clip hausa wolves
is better than the dark below which was
better than core destiny so what does
house of wolves do right for starters
the story missions that kick off the dlc
are no longer filled with out of
contacts tinklebutt dialogue in core
destiny most of the story was about
Rasputin crotas legions and other plot
points in the first DLC that players
hadn't seen yet House of wolves dialogue
and character moments told by pet
revenge deal with what players are
currently doing and actually makes sense
the mission locations are buried at a
new vehicle the heavy bike and aren't
too tough on the eyes something added
for new players are missions in the
vault of glass involving Oracle puzzles
and also jumping platform moments later
in the DLC that train people for the
game's first rate in terms of offering
something to players you just like to
shoot things the new sidearm class
kicking it off with the vestian dynasty
is excellent high rates of fire arc
damage and quick reloads make the pistol
book a great primary or finisher in pvp
and PVE this stands in stark contrast
with protozoans primary quest weapon the
upgradeable husk of the pit that was
rapidly abandoned by players the pistol
also gives destiny a more classic
shooter feel for old school shooter fans
house of wolves also brings armor and
weapon diversity in a way that hasn't
existed in the game before previously
all high level characters were whatever
max light level armor they possessed so
for a long time everyone looked like
they just woke up and got out of bed
from the vault of glass or crotas end'
subsequent exotics and events such as
the iron banner did change a people's
look a bit but not nearly enough hausa
wolves now allows players to send any
legendary or exotic piece of armor or
weapon to max level in addition the dlc
shells at new legendary armor without
elaborate upgrade trees at a pretty
recent clip so now player styles are
only limited by their luck with etheric
light drops on a side note the entire
currency system has been made simple
with a currency exchange ultimately
we're going to have to see if House of
wolves has enough content to keep people
interested most of my colleagues are on
their way to hitting max level in the
first week and if there's one thing
missing from house of wolves it's
loadout slots since the prison of elders
the highest level content is about
fighting all the enemy types in one
sitting each with different types of
elemental shields the lack of in-game
loadouts just seems like a huge
oversight also lack of matchmaking above
28 and the prison eval there still bugs
me internet matchmaking sites have
proven again and again that bungees
philosophy is just wrong when it comes
to match me in conclusion is house of
wolves good I can honestly say that it
makes destiny better well you still have
to do your weekly destiny chores to
enjoy the game say two or three night
falls maybe nine prison of elders a
trial of osiris card or two well it is
destiny you're just not going to find a
hundred hours of unique content like you
wouldn't say the witcher 3 whether or
not that makes house of wolves good is
up to you
you